[تصفيق]
بين ليل وضحاها اصبحت دبابه الالمانيه
محله تصاعد خلاف غربي داخلي وتصاعدي توتر
الاوروبيين
ذائعه الصيت ذات الامكانات العسكريه
الفائقه تطوق اوكرانيا لاشراكها في ساحه
المعركه المحتدمه مع روسيا ولكن ما الذي
يجعلها في بؤره ضوء ساحه المعركه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
دبابات امريكيه نقل عنه موقع
1945 فان الدبابات الالمانيه تتمتع بتطور
انظمه الرؤيه والاستهداف النهاري والليلي
مقارنه بدبابات برادلي الامريكيه التي
اعتدى عليها القائد كما يتمتع المدفع
الرئيسي لليوبارد بثبات كبيره وقدره فائقه
على ضرب الاهداف هذا بالاضافه الى
امتلاكها دروعا اماميه قادره على مواجهه
نظيرتها روسيه الى جانب نقاء انظمه
الاتصال الداخلي بين افراد كتيبه اليوبار
الاثنين
قدره قتاليه واخرى فنيه تتمتع بها
سرعه فائقه في تزويد محركاتها التي تعمل
بالديزل الى جانب نظره تعرضها لاعطال
الميكانيكيه ثم سهوله نقلها من الدول
المجاوره والدعامه في شرق اوروبا
لكنها تواجه تحديات لتحقيق الهدف من
وجودها في ساحه المعركه ابرزها استجابه
الجنود الاوكرانيين لعمليات التدريب عليها
من قبل الخبرات العسكريه الغربيه
ووافقا للقائد العسكري الامريكي تواجه
اليوبارد تحديا اخر وهو الاصعب يتمثل في
مدى قدرتها على الصمود في وجه المسارات
الروسيه
وبقدر ما تحتاج اوكرانيا لليوبارد اثنين
الالمانيه تحتاج ايضا للاستعداد على رده
فعل روسيه تاقلمت وتكيفت مع امدادات
عسكريه غربيه سابقه وضلت تجد مخرجا
لاستمرار مواجهه عسكريه عنيده
علي السمان العربيه